I work out what's happening to this
limit right and so far we've been using
like funky algebraic approaches and sort
of tricks with trig and Radian measure
to try and manipulate this but there
aren't really many tricks with this you
just sort of have to bash it out okay
now rather than getting you guys to get
calculators up and really bash it out
I'm gonna get Excel to bash the out step
okay so if you've never used Excel and
my formulas in Excel then hold on to
your hats okay it's actually very very
powerful very useful okay so let me show
you first I want to think about values
of HS they're getting smaller okay
now I could actually just put in some
manual values of H that are getting
closer and closer to zero but instead
I'm gonna get Excel to do the work for
me so here's what we're gonna do
let's start as I get further down I want
to have numbers of smaller one
so I'm gonna take that number and I'm
gonna divide by two
okay so I'll have a half here and then
I'll have a corner and Aiden they're
just gonna progressively get smaller
okay so there's a half and I'll take
that
let's paste it a few times okay so we're
getting some pretty small numbers yeah
if that's so small that Excel can handle
them so that's not a scientific notation
okay so we've got we've literally got
values of H that are approaching zero
okay
now taking the limit means okay tell me
what happens to this this whole the
infraction as these values change okay
sure
what if I actually got I've got to the H
minus 1 on the top so that's 2 so the
power of and I want the age which is
this value over here you see that
- one okay how's that that makes sense
that's my numerator and then I'm
dividing by H which again is that same
number okay so before I press enter the
formula banishes do you see what I'm
doing a - it's because it's a and this
is the second row right that's just my H
and then this will be the next section
in southern Seoul is okay so there's one
better okay now you like oh well
actually that makes sense through the
one - one on one - that makes it so now
here's where the computer does all the
work I'm going to get all of those for
all of these different values of H so
let's go down and I'm gonna paste this
okay all right now okay so what's what's
up can I smell the action what's going
on
well for starters this limit it's
getting smaller okay which sort of makes
sense because this number is getting
bigger all right but so is this one what
you're dividing by okay so it's getting
smaller and smaller that's war okay but
then you're from here to here
you've lost like point one eight okay
that's how much going on from here to
here you've lost about point O seven and
then he pointed five and point out two
and then point eight so in other words
as I go step by step I'm losing less and
less okay
so I'm not getting smaller forever I'm
actually approaching something that's
why we're using a limit okay so let's
keep going as the numbers get smaller
and I could keep going if you like it
stuff they hit a brick wall right you
notice all of these ones I've got on the
screen the first three digits are all
the same okay and I can keep going and
they'll stay the same and then you've
got very very new changes okay now
evidently I'm a pushing some number
point six 93 one for something something
something yeah you guys probably that
number doesn't mean us to you but and
this
there's not much of a way for me to say
walk okay don't you remember this number
it's very common this number is now you
get your calculator out you can remove
the angle of that back to the border
that you want I'm gonna try it's not
it's money is 2.7 something brother okay
what is this knob it's related to either
I want you get your cap back and I want
you to type in you got it I want you to
type in four on one side while you
calculate out what's your type in
natural log of 2 it's 2 because okay now
exactly how close did I get it's zero
point six nine one three one four seven
what what I saw I got I got pretty close
I got you know a lot of decimal point
places close right so that's what this
is Bridget I could keep on going if you
like this excel would eventually run out
of decimal places this is my limit
okay now hold on a second what was the
significance of this number in it this
number this log to correspond to what
this limit was approaching okay this
whole part here so this derivative is
therefore equal to two to the x times
natural one
okay now that's kind of interesting I
guess what significance does it have
well you can try this out again right
and you can put in three games or tend
to be is whatever number you like okay
you're gonna get this same thing being
able to mount the front so for example
if I change to a three this would be a 3
a 3 and a 3 so I would again factor out
a 3 and then I have 3d HP on ok and I
can crush the numbers if you like you'll
get 3 to the X log 3 okay check it out
right so something's going on here
right now he's my pad let's generalize
first maybe you know that contend with
the fact that I used the computer to do
it ok but it's it's sufficient for us
that if I differentiate any kind of
exponential function where it's some
constant to the power X so let's call
the Clinton Hey yes ok so that's going
to give me let's do this what's the log
3 it's just a number isn't it so the
derivative is the exponential function
times some number right and that's what
we expected by an intuition that the
derivative is a another kind of
exponential but not exactly the same and
that not exactly the same is this log a
number and you should probably had in
where a is a real number so that's the
distinguisher from X extra variable
Perez natural my mother for long days